well the personal philosophy that I've
developed is to be independent and not I
work very hard to not let my own
political point of view get in the way
of what I do I think that's an awfully
important thing to do for four people in
the polling business and in the media
more generally to to not let your own
views about about an issue or about an
individual color the way you write
questions the way you interpret
questions if you begin to bring your own
take two things you will do yourself in
ultimately in terms of writing accurate
and honest reports the other important
thing to recognize about what we do is
unlike a lot of material that's that's
that put forth about politics and media
we get we have a report card you know
come election day you know the day
before the election we put out a poll
and we say this is what we think is
going to happen or this is where the
electorate is as of today and we also
talk about what might happen between
today and tomorrow and the world gets to
citizens we are on the public record the
world gets to see whether we're right or
wrong now having that challenge and
having that being put up to that kind of
scrutiny you really work very hard to
get it right are one of the great things
about my career as I worked with the
pioneers I work for the gorge captain
and I could always remember gallops
being completely flummoxed by people who
would accuse them of being you know a
Republican or a Democrat you know what
Gallup wanted was to get the damn Pole
right and I think that's what most of us
who work in the public not most of us
all of us who work in the public domain
I mean the worst thing that world is
you've had
all that's shown consistently this that
or the other thing and it and reality
turns out to be something else
you